[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 con
el 50,90% de los votos Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva del partido de los trabajadores
es el nuevo presidente electo de Brasil
el actual presidente Yair bolsonaro
derrotado en esta contienda electoral no
ha dado declaraciones frente a los
resultados
el gobierno de la República de Corea
declaró luto nacional tras la tragedia
que dejó más de 150 muertos y unos 80
heridos en una estampida ocurrida en la
ciudad de seúl la capital del país
durante la celebración de Halloween las
autoridades aseguran que investigan en
profundidad las causas de este suceso
y las exportaciones de granos continúan
bloqueadas en Ucrania luego de que Rusia
suspendiera su participación en el
acuerdo que permitía los envíos a
diferentes partes del mundo la otan
pidió a Moscú reconsiderar sus decisión
mientras que la ONU Busca poner fin a la
suspensión de esta iniciativa
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora
ya Brasil tiene nuevo presidente y se
llama Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva Quien
ganó con el escrutinio con el 50,90%
frente al mandatario al actual
presidente Jair bolsonaro quien obtuvo
el
49,10% de los votos Lula regresa así al
poder en un Brasil completamente
dividido con un discurso lleno de
promesas en materia económica social y
de medio ambiente en sus primeras
palabras a los brasileños también habló
de unidad y de igualdad escuchemos a
partir de primero a partir del primero
de enero de 2023 voy a gobernar para 215
millones de brasileños y brasileños y no
solamente para los que votaron por mí no
existen dos Brasil somos un único país
un único pueblo una gran nación
[Aplausos]
este 30 de octubre histórico la mayoría
del pueblo brasileño dejó bien claro que
desea más y no menos democracia
desea más y no menos inclusión social y
oportunidades para todos
desea más y no menos respeto y
entendimiento entre los brasileños
en resumen
desea más libertad fraternidad en
nuestro país y las calles de diferentes
ciudades brasileñas se han convertido en
el escenario de manifestaciones de Los
Seguidores de Lula quienes celebran su
triunfo y su regreso al poder justamente
en la ciudad de Sao Paulo el ahora
presidente electo fue donde esperó los
resultados de las votaciones y allí
miles de personas se congregaron en la
céntrica avenida paulista para recibir
los resultados de estas votaciones
escuchemos Hola
significa esperanza la esperanza de vida
mejores la esperanza de que volveremos a
ser felices porque nos conocemos
es la vida es el dolor y es la victoria
de terminación mucha determinación y
sobre todo justicia él es la justicia
tengo miedo de que Lula no asuma el
cargo sí habrá un golpe de estado No lo
sé pero le apoyamos luchamos hasta el
final
impresiones de algunos de los ciudadanos
brasileños frente a Este triunfo de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva quien es un
veterano político que vuelve a la acción
Después de 12 años de estar alejado de
la política y también después de haber
pasado por un escándalo de corrupción el
líder de 77 años dirigirá por tercera
vez Brasil con un ambicioso programa que
pretende reactivar la economía de este
país y también reducir las desigualdades
miremos Cuáles han sido algunos de los
puntos más destacados de su recorrido
político vuelve al escenario tras 12
años en el banquillo a sus 76 años Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva está listo para
liderar Brasil una tercera vez
campañas probablemente la más importante
de su larga carrera política para el
expresidente se trata de preservar y
proteger lo que queda de su legado
después de cuatro años con Yair
bolsonaro en el poder
nunca actuaremos como nuestro adversario
que trata de enmascarar su competencia
buscando peleas con todo el mundo y
mintiendo siete veces al día después de
dos exitosos períodos como presidente en
2002 y 2006 Lula no pudo presentarse a
un tercer mandato consecutivo y dejó el
cargo en 2010 con un asombroso 83% de
aprobación durante su mandato aumentó el
salario mínimo Y puso en marcha una
serie de programas sociales que sacaron
de la pobreza a más de 30 millones de
brasileños pero la trayectoria de Lula
Dion Hero cuando fue investigado por su
papel en el escándalo de corrupción
conocido como lava yato en 2017 fue
declarado culpable de conceder contratos
guberna a cambio de un apartamento y fue
condenado a 12 años de cárcel siempre
defendió su inocencia y denunció una
conspiración para impedirle presentarse
a las elecciones de 2018 fue víctima de
una de las mayores persecuciones
políticas y jurídicas de la historia de
este país
en 2019 Lula fue liberado a la espera de
una apelación
en 2021 su condena fue anulada por un
juez por motivos procesales desde
entonces el ex presidente ha estado
preparando su regreso a la política en
mayo de 2022 lanzó oficialmente su
campaña con un ambicioso programa
reabrir la economía apoyar a las
comunidades vulnerables indígenas
proteger la selva tropical y restaurar
la imagen Internacional del país
una tarea difícil para la que Lula
reunió una amplia coalición eligiendo al
político de Centro derecha Gerardo
alkmin su antiguo rival presidencial en
2006 como compañero de fórmula para
ayudarle a derrocar a Jair bolsonaro y
entre tanto Los líderes de América
Latina también de Estados Unidos y de
algunos países de Europa ya han
felicitado el triunfo en las urnas de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva destacaron el
proceso democrático en Brasil y también
se mostraron abiertos a trabajar con el
mandatario electo en diferentes temas
como la integración la y el materia de
medio ambiente veamos algunas de las
reacciones Miguel Díaz canal presidente
de Cuba Cuba te felicita querido
compañero atrasaron tu Victoria con
métodos atroces pero no pudieron impedir
que vencieras con el voto del pueblo
regresa Lula regresa el PT Brasil
regresa a la justicia social también el
presidente de Chile Gabriel borich Lula
alegría También haciendo referencia al
tren al triunfo del mandatario electo
por los brasileños desde la Casa Blanca
el gobierno del presidente Joe biden en
Estados Unidos envió mis felicitaciones
a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva por su
elección como próximo presidente de
Brasil espero trabajemos juntos para
continuar la cooperación entre nuestros
dos países en los próximos meses
también el presidente de Francia Manuel
macón desde el otro lado del Atlántico
Felicidades querido Lula en su elección
que abre una nueva página en la historia
de Brasil juntos uniremos nuestras
fuerzas para hacer frente a los
numerosos retos comunes y renovar el
vínculo de amistad entre nuestros dos
países
Antonio Costa Primer Ministro de
Portugal un país importante para las
relaciones con Europa y Brasil ya he
tenido la oportunidad de felicitar
calurosamente a Lula en su elección como
presidente de la república de Brasil
Espero que trabajemos juntos en los
próximos años En beneficio de Portugal y
Brasil pero también en torno a las
grandes causas globales
ahora el nuevo mandatario de los
brasileños asumirá importantes retos en
temas económicos sociales también de
medio ambiente y sobre todo geopolíticos
mientras se busca una Unión nacional
entre los ciudadanos brasileños veamos
el informe de lea Uriel y Andrés triviño
el país que ASUME Luis Ignacio lulada
Brasil eligió a su mandatario de los
próximos cuatro años en medio de la
polarización que dejan estas elecciones
el nuevo presidente tendrá que tomar
decisiones contundentes para combatir
temas como el hombre según datos
oficiales 33 millones de hogares pasan
hambre en el país sudamericano es decir
el 15% de su población Y aunque las
Naciones Unidas lo sacó del mapa del
hombre en 2014 la cifra ha retrocedido
durante las últimas dos décadas en
septiembre la tasa de desempleo en
Brasil disminuyó por séptimo mes
consecutivo hasta el nivel más bajo
desde 2015 sin embargo la agencia
Nacional de estadísticas informó que
alrededor de 9.5 millones de brasileños
se encuentra sin trabajo actualmente
Brasil todavía sufre las consecuencias
económicas de la pandemia Y aunque se
espera que el producto interno bruto
para 2022 sea del 2.7% siendo superior a
la de Estados Unidos este no representa
un crecimiento exponencial el medio
ambiente es uno de los temas cruciales
durante la administración de bolsonaroz
se le acusó de no proteger activistas
indígenas y de desarrollar políticas a
favor de las Industrias según el
Instituto Nacional de pesquisas
especiales más de 47.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de zonas verdes fueron
deforestadas durante dicha
administración en cuanto al liderazgo
geopolítico Brasil ocupó El séptimo
puesto de Las mayores economías del
mundo entre 2010 y 2014 en comparación a
los últimos años posicionándose en la
casilla número 12 de igual manera se
esperaba que el país sudamericano
asumiera el liderazgo del bloque
económico de los brics sin embargo las
estrategias no han sido suficientes para
lograr su objetivo
pasemos ahora a otros hechos destacados
de la jornada al menos 153 fallecidos y
82 heridos es el saldo de la estampida
que ocurrió el sábado en la noche en la
ciudad de seúl en la capital coreana
mientras cientos de personas celebraban
allí las festividades de Halloween
muchos murieron asfixiados y la
población coreana empieza a cuestionar
la gestión de seguridad del gobierno
central después de que testigos oculares
denunciaran que había falta de personal
de la policía en esa concurrida zona de
bares en el centro de la ciudad de seúl
algunos espectadores pueden encontrar
las imágenes que van a ver a
continuación en el reportaje
perturbadoras el informe de Juan Pablo
lucumí
una de las peores tragedias de Corea del
Sur en años cientos de personas llegaron
al barrio y tehón para llorar a las más
de 150 víctimas que dejó la estampida
humana tras las celebraciones de
Halloween en el estrecho callejón que
conecta la principal Avenida del Barrio
con una concurrida zona de bares muchos
aún buscan a sus seres queridos no pude
encontrarla si revise la lista Pero el
nombre de quien Busco no está allí otros
lamentan lo ocurrido y gozan de su buena
suerte en los últimos meses había estado
viniendo a itevón pero no vine ayer
porque pensé que habría mucha gente y
estaba preocupado porque podían pasar
cosas malas estaba muy ansioso e
inquieto no pude dormir bien la opinión
pública surcoreana pone en duda los
estándares de seguridad según el
presidente la prioridad de su gobierno
será apoyar a las familias de las
víctimas y avanzar con una investigación
en profundidad para determinar las
causas de la tragedia
Halloween
una tragedia y un desastre que no
debería haber ocurrido tuvo lugar en el
corazón de seúl durante la celebración
de Halloween anoche expresó mis
condolencias a las víctimas del
incidente inesperado y espero que las
personas que resultaron heridas se
recuperen pronto mi corazón está con las
familias de las víctimas que sufren
angustia de perder a sus seres queridos
el gobierno designará un período de luto
nacional a partir de hoy hasta que el
incidente sea controlado y pondrá en
máxima prioridad en los asuntos
estatales la recuperación y las medidas
de seguimiento del incidente
según la agencia de noticias jonat entre
los muertos del incidente del sábado
había personas de China Irán Rusia
Estados Unidos Australia Uzbekistán
Vietnam kazajistán Austria sri lanka
Tailandia Noruega y Francia el
presidente de Estados Unidos y los
primeros ministros de Canadá y Reino
Unido expresaron sus condolencias en
redes sociales mientras varias estrellas
de k-pop como integrantes del grupo bts
cancelaron sus eventos musicales luego
de la tragedia
y en otros temas Ucrania informó que la
decisión de Rusia de suspender su
participación en el acuerdo de
exportación de granos bloquea cerca de 2
millones de toneladas de granos que son
lo suficiente para alimentar acerca de 7
millones de personas el Ministerio de
exteriores de Ucrania informó que hay
176 barcos bloqueados en el mar Negro
por su parte Turquía asegura que va a
inspeccionar los barcos que ya habían
salido de los puertos ucranianos Durante
los días previos ampliamos la
información desde la ciudad de Estambul
con nuestro corresponsal permanente allí
adria Rocha
Turquía ha confirmado esta mañana el
cierre según Turquía temporal según
Rusia indefinido del centro de
coordinación conjunta que se creó en
julio de este mismo año en Estambul a
través del acuerdo que al que llegaron a
Ucrania y Rusia con la mediación de
Naciones Unidas y de Turquía para
permitir las exportaciones de grano y
cereal que había sido bloqueado en
Ucrania después de la invasión rusa en
febrero
este año Turquía explicado Hoy después
del comunicado de ayer asegurando Rusia
que rompía el acuerdo que el acuerdo
será roto sí aunque será temporalmente y
que se espera que te entre hoy y mañana
los barcos que salieron cargados de
cereal de Ucrania hace unos pocos días
que ahora mismo están esperando en
Estambul para ser inspeccionados serán
inspeccionados y se permitirá que
continúen con sus rutas en los próximos
días sin embargo ha confirmado Turquía
que no saldrán más barcos desde los
puertos de Odessa y del sur de Ucrania
hasta que se confirme hace que se pueda
renegociar otra vez el acuerdo dice
Turquía que quiere renegociar y quiere
reunido las dos partes otra vez encima
de la mesa algo difícil sobre todo por
la parte rusa que se retiró
unilateralmente de este acuerdo y por la
parte ucraniana que he dicho hoy el
ministro de exteriores dimitroculeva que
está retirada Rusia demuestra que no se
puede hablar negociar con los rusos
nikon Moscú
Y al menos 100 personas murieron y otras
300 resultaron heridas como consecuencia
del atentado con dos autos bomba
perpetrado en mogadillo la capital de
somalia el gobierno condenó el ataque
dirigido contra el Ministerio de
Educación y también aseguró que se trata
de un acto cruel del grupo terrorista Al
shabat que está vinculado al qaeda y que
controla una gran parte de ese país
africano
esto en las noticias siga con nosotros
[Música]